well there shouldn't really have been
anyone here at all anywhere you should
there because it was first thing this
morning that the vigil was cancelled
and throughout the afternoon it became
clear that there were going to be large
numbers of people here
come six o'clock when the vigil would
have started and it was peaceful as you
say to
at the beginning there was a minute
silence uh
but then uh the chanting began now
initially
it was um chance about
needing to end violence against women
and then gradually it changed
to anger at the police having prevented
the vigil from going ahead
and then it grew to anger at the way
that the
police were handling it according to
the protesters here and what we saw were
loud
and furious clashes between
groups of uh protesters and mourners
and the police and some individuals
being
led away flanked by police officers
in high views and followed by crowds of
really
angry people shouting and chanting
as they were led away to the police
vans you know this wasn't what
uh reclaimed these streets the
organizers originally
had expected i spoke to one of the
organizers earlier and she said that she
thought
initially that it would be maybe 50
friends that's what they thought about
to start with but it really
really gained momentum which is why
we've seen
such large numbers of people here today
and actually it's important to note that
when it became clear that the event
wasn't going to go on
the organizers set up um a fundraising
page first thing this morning
to raise money for women's charities it
was money they said that they would have
needed to pay
bills uh if they were fined ten thousand
pounds per event for having organized
during the lockdown
um so uh instead uh they have raised
nearly half a million pounds already in
one day
alone and tommy's in downing street this
evening lots of political
fallout then tom from tonight's scenes
in clapham
yeah serious questions it seems being
raised for
the metropolitan police and how they
have handled this extremely
sensitive situation we've had a short
statement in the last few minutes from
the home secretary priti patel
where she says some of the footage
circulating online from the vigil in
clapham is
upsetting i have asked the metropolitan
police for a full report
on what happened we've also just
recently heard from the mayor of london
sadiq khan he goes slightly further
saying
that the scenes in clapham common are
unacceptable and that the police have a
responsibility to enforce covet laws but
from the images i've seen he says
it's clear the response was at times
neither appropriate nor proportionate
i'm in contact with the commissioner and
urgently seeking
an explanation similar tone from the
labour leader kia starmer who says the
scenes in clapham this evening are
deeply disturbing
women came to mourn sarah everard they
should have been able to do so
peacefully
i share their anger and upset that how
this has been handled this
was not the way to police this pro
protest now clearly those are questions
largely
for the police but i think there will be
growing questions too
for government in the days ahead the
high court
hearing that took place yesterday to
establish whether it was
legal for this vigil to go ahead
in the end saw the court say it wasn't
really for them to decide that it was
not clear from the coveted regulations
whether
protests were banned that it was a
judgment for the police to take
in any defined uh situation and i think
that is going to raise questions
about the vagaries perhaps of the
coveted regulations and the impact
on civil liberties certainly it's been
seized upon
by steve baker conservative backbencher
an early indication perhaps
of the kind of pressure boris johnson
might now see
in relation to coveted regulations steve
baker saying these are unspeakable
scenes
you need to change lockdown law now
boris johnson this evening a candle has
been
lit outside number 10 in memory of sarah
everett
but we've yet to hear anything from the
prime minister himself